the washington post faced a lot of
criticism yesterday
because of a headline announcing the
death of isis leader abu
bakr al-baghdadi who was killed in a
raid by u.s
forces okay here was the initial
headline
abu bakr al-baghdadi islamic state's
terrorist in chief
dies at 48. now there was criticism some
people
a lot of people actually found that too
glib so the washington post later
changed the headline
to this one abu bakr al-baghdadi
austere religious scholar at helm of
islamic state
dies at 48.
yes that's that's real they did that
yeah now
then
then that headline obviously was
criticized for being way too
complimentary so they changed it
yet again i wanted to find out who was
responsible for this whole mess so here
to speak to me now via satellite
is washington post obituary editor
steven cruz stephen thank you very much
for being here
no no problem yeah thanks now what's
going on here stephen
well allow me to apologize yet again for
those first two headlines
they did not meet the washington post's
rigorous editorial standards
thank you good night oh no no wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute no
come back
come back don't walk away no one walks
away from a camera uh
and i understand sir i understand making
a mistake
once but twice yes well we wanted the
headline to convey the gravitas of the
situation
and i believe we over-corrected but
thankfully that headline has been
replaced with this one
okay abu bakr al-baghdadi and his
beautiful beard johnny 48.
now wait a minute no that's not no
no that's ridiculous that's even more
complimentary i agree
which is why i fought to change it to
something more neutral
okay abu bakr al-baghdadi jazz fan
whiskey connoisseur motivational speaker
dead at 48. no no wait a minute
no that almost sounds like a celebrity's
obituary
well if you didn't like that when you're
really not gonna like where we landed
next
ah boo
that's just awful i totally agree
totally which is why we scrapped it and
went with this one
this will make you feel old the og isis
founder is dead
no no no no no no no you can't do that
that's not good
correct terrible so we took a step back
and finally solved it with this one
naughty hottie albuk daddy goes potty
loses earthly body
you know what no no
no okay okay fine whole week there
that's perfect
which is why we ultimately went with our
backup okay
our losses 72 virgins gained abu bakr
al-baghdadi ascends to the boom town
in the clouds you know what no no
you need to be fired immediately you
need to be fired i agree and
i i agree and i was fired after i posted
this
[Laughter]
all right uh thanks for being here
you're an idiot steven cruz everybody
i'm sorry
you